[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a coming-of-age comedy drama
film called three idiots spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
30 year old farhan is on board a flight
that is minutes away from taking off he
gets a call from someone and the news
they relay shocks him to the core right
when the airplane takes off he gets up
from his seat trying to get to the
stewardess but before he can sharp pain
in his chest makes him fall unconscious
the pilots land the plane back on the
runway and farhan is rushed outside in a
wheelchair all of a sudden he opens his
eyes proving that he was faking the
heart attack he does a few jumping jacks
and tells his caretaker he seems to be
fine before running away then he rushes
to his friend raju's home he also calls
raju and tells him that their third
friend rancho is back in town the news
shocks raju as much as it did to farhan
he quickly wears a shirt and runs
outside with his shoes still in his
hands when the friends meet farhan
reminds him that he forgot to wear his
pants still both friends did not seem to
care because the missing pants are
nothing compared to reuniting with their
long-lost friend rancho they go to their
former engineering college and meet
chatur their college rival and an
egocentric gullible man it turns out
that chatur had made a bet with farhan
and his group when they were in college
they had decided to meet 10 years later
on the 5th of september to see who is
the most successful out of them all
while everyone else forgot about this
stupid bet chatura remembered it and
brought them all to the same place again
he also reveals that he is the vice
president of rockledge corporation and a
millionaire the other two do not care
about his success and only want to meet
rancho it is revealed that rancho left
randomly after college and has never
contacted them since they had given up
on looking for him after several tries
as they are about to beat chatur up for
wasting their time he claims that rancho
is in simla he wants to take them on a
trip to simla to get them together and
show them how far he has come in life
farhan and raju are ready to come with
him and do not care even if he is trying
to prove they're inferior to him a
flashback shows us the time when farhan
entered college for his freshman year he
and raju were given a single room to
share alongside rancho farhan and raju
had problems of their own farhan didn't
want to become an engineer and was only
doing it for his father while raju was
too scared of the future to concentrate
on the present but rancho was different
the first time they met him was while
being bullied by the seniors on their
first night of college it was a
tradition for the senior guys to get the
freshman boys naked and make them bow it
was considered a way for the freshmen to
show respect to their elders it was
probably also a way for their elders to
exhibit their closeted homosexuality
without consequence when everyone else
quietly followed the tradition rancho
did not he locked himself inside his
dorm room and refused to come out even
when the leader of the bullies
threatened him to teach him a lesson the
bully is about to pee in front of his
door but rancho is smarter than the
others he joins an electric wire to a
spoon and slowly puts it under the door
when the bully pees on it he gets
electrocuted everyone laughs and admires
him for his brilliant idea farhan and
raju are impressed and confused by
rancho's interesting personality
following that we are introduced to the
college's strict dean viru known as
virus among the students he is a typical
orthodox man who thinks life is a race
and the students should do exactly what
they are told in order to be successful
one thing virus hates the most is
wasting time for the same reason he has
velcro stuck to all his shirts instead
of buttons and hooks to his ties every
year virus gathers the first-year
students and gives them a speech about a
special pen that he got from his teacher
the pen as he says is an astronaut's pen
that the scientists have invented after
years of research to be able to write in
space he has been waiting to give the
pen to an extraordinary student like
himself but in his 20 years of career
hasn't found a student good enough for
it in other words virus thinks very
highly of himself virus has given the
same speech to every batch of students
the college has ever had and never in
his life has anyone asked him a question
but this time rancho inquires why the
astronauts didn't use a pencil instead
of a pen virus is left shocked all he
can say is he will get back to the
question after the speech the school's
janitor and child worker named
millimeter praises rancho for this
question rancho gives him some money to
buy a school uniform advising him to
enter any class of any school without
being noticed his interesting
personality is amusing to farhan but
raju thinks he will cause them trouble
rancho isn't like most of the students
who work as the professor's puppets he
asks his own questions makes his own
answers and genuinely loves engineering
but the teachers always mistake his
attentiveness for mischief and send him
out of the class but rancho sits in
another random class when thrown out of
one he is in college not for a diploma
but to study and that is an incredible
life lesson that we should all be so
lucky to learn there is only one other
like him in the college roy from the
fourth year he has been working on a
project that is genius but virus refuses
to look at it because roy is behind the
submission date he even calls roy's
father and bluntly tells him his son
won't graduate the news is too much for
the hopeful father to handle but virus
doesn't care he is absolute about not
giving roy a second chance roy throws
his project and rancho finds it later he
sees that the machine is innovative and
only needs a little polishing for the
next week he works on the project and
completes it when it's done they fly the
drone to roy's room only to see his
corpse they run to his room and witness
that he has committed the unthinkable
during his funeral rancho tells virus
that roy was murdered by the college's
system of pressuring students virus
takes the comment personally and writes
a letter to farhan and raju's parents
telling them that rancho is a bad
influence on their sons virus should be
in jail the very next day farhan's
father calls them home and asks rancho
to stay away from his son rancho ignores
his words distracted by the wildlife
pictures on the wall it turns out that
farhan wants to be a wildlife
photographer but has taken engineering
because of his father rancho tries to
convince his father otherwise but it is
not enough to eradicate his deep-rooted
and shallow principle after that they go
to raju's home and finds out that his
family lives below poverty his father is
bedridden and retired while his sister
is getting older but no one wants to
marry her the family's responsibility
falls upon raju which is why he is
always so scared of the future later the
friends pretend to be guests at a
wedding to enjoy the food rancho notices
a girl named pia and her fiance talking
about her watch by the conversation it
is clear that the guy suhas is a
materialistic man who is only marrying
her for her status rancho tells pia what
he thinks about suhas and drops a
dressing into his shoes to prove to her
how materialistic he is as expected
suhas cries out the price of his shoes
and yells at the waiter for ruining them
intrigued by rancho's personality pia
does some digging and finds out that he
is her father viruses student to the
guy's misfortune the wedding they broke
into is virus's elder daughters pia
tells her father about the three and
gets them in trouble the night before
exams chatura slips adult magazines into
everyone's dorm room in an attempt to
distract them when rancho gets a hint of
this he is determined to teach him a
lesson one day shatur is invited to give
a hindi speech for an important charity
event but since he is awful at hindi he
learns the speech not understanding a
single word of it what he doesn't know
is that rancho has changed some
important words in the text with words
like breast and assault on the day of
the event chatur unknowingly insults the
vips with his absurd speech after
getting in trouble for it chatur is
enraged he challenges the guys to bet on
who will be the most successful in 10
years and writes the date september 5th
on the wall one day rancho bumps into
pia and sue haas outside a jewelry store
suhas has just bought her an expensive
watch rancho does an experiment and
makes her pretend she lost the watch
suhas loses his temper and calls her an
idiot once again showing his
materialistic side pia breaks up with
him after handing him the watch back
right after rancho gets a call informing
him that raju's father is having a
seizure he and pia drive to raju's house
and get his father to the hospital just
in time to save his life raju is beyond
thankful and sorry to his friend pia
sees how much rancho cares about his
friends and starts to fall for him
finally the results of the first
semester exams are published farhan and
raju rank in the lowest position but
they are happy that at least they didn't
fail then to their utmost surprise
rancho ranks in the first position
chature who comes second and virus who
hates rancho's guts are the saddest
people in the crowd virus takes a
picture together with the passing class
with the first and second ranking
students by his side back in the present
raju and farhan reach simla along with
chatur to meet rancho they arrive at his
house according to shatur's location and
find that rancho's father passed away
that morning when everyone is mourning
they approach a man however to their
confusion the man who claims to be
rancho is someone else even the picture
they took together in college is
different the guys returned to a nearby
restaurant to think of their next step
as they talk chature mentions a great
scientist and inventor named wang do who
is going to sign a million dollar deal
with his company next week the other two
cannot care less about the so-called
great scientist and want to know why
rancho's identity was stolen they
returned to the house and asked the fake
rancho about the real one the man brings
out a gun to intimidate them it works on
shatur who runs away like a coward but
farhan and raju are adamant they in turn
threaten to throw his father's ashes
into the toilet if he doesn't tell them
the truth the man finally reveals that
he is the real rancho and the guy who
went to college with them is his
gardener's son who they call choate in
childhood he used to do rancho's
homework and study for him when rancho's
father found out he allowed choate to
keep going because he needed education
and rancho needed a degree that way
choate had to return after graduating
because he had promised he wouldn't keep
in contact after raju and farhan find
out about his new address they leave to
look for him again when the guys were in
the final year of college they were
nervous about the job recruit taking
place in two months while giving a
speech about recruitment virus insults
farhan and raju declaring that they will
never land the jobs he calls them losers
and makes fun of them in front of
everyone that night the three get drunk
in anger while drunk rancho reveals that
farhan has a letter in his bag addressed
to his favorite photographer who he
wants to work with he also calls raju a
coward for constantly worrying about the
future raju and farhan in turn promise
to do as rancho says if he confesses his
feelings to pia they go to virus's house
and break into pia's room rancho finds
her sleeping and confesses his feelings
only to find out that he had been
talking to her pregnant sister mona the
girls are both impressed by his proposal
soon virus wakes up and finds urine on
his front door he also notices raju's
face in the dark the guys are so drunk
that they fall asleep in class and wake
up a few hours later when everyone is
studying virus storms into the classroom
and finds raju still drunk from last
night later raju is called to his office
and told that he will be expelled once
and for all he begs the dean to give him
a second chance but the man just ignores
him with no hope left of a good life
raju committed the unthinkable
in the following scene we see rancho and
farhan rushing him to the hospital
thankfully he survives but goes into a
state of paralysis pia who is also a
doctor informs them that raju can see
and hear them so they should act happy
and motivate him to get better quicker
starting that day rancho and farhan do
everything in their power to bring raju
back they throw parties for him tell him
fake news that might make him happy and
buy his mother clothes that she always
wanted his expulsion is also terminated
but even that good news doesn't bring
him back then one day rancho lies to him
that farhan is going to marry his sister
who is desperate for a husband the news
makes raju come out of paralysis with
his first words he calls them rascals
and asks them to stop lying following
that he gets better in no time on the
day of the recruit farhan gets a letter
back from his favorite photographer who
invites him to be his assistant now all
he has to do is ask his father for
permission similarly raju also gives up
on all his fortune rings and goes to the
interview fearlessly he tells the
interviewers everything about his bad
grades and the reason he was about to be
expelled his attitude is unlike anything
that the interviewers have ever seen so
they offer him a job meanwhile after an
emotional conversation farhan also
convinces his father to let him take up
photography after the commotion farhan
and raju take off their pants in front
of rancho to pay their respect as per
the college's ritual however virus who
is sure that raju will fail is not happy
to be proven wrong while drunk he tells
his daughters that he will set the exam
questions and make it the most difficult
ever pia is worried for the guys so she
brings the second key to virus's office
to them urging them to steal the papers
then back in the present the guys call
pia to tell her that they found rancho
however they discovered that she is
getting married in a few hours they
divert from the original route to pick
her up as well initially pia refuses to
come with them even though she is still
in love with rancho she sits beside her
future husband only to find out that the
man behind the headwear is raju he has
taken the groom's place in a desperate
attempt to convince her eventually they
run away while the guests watched them
in shock the night before the final
exams farhan and rancho had a way to
steal the question papers they do not
want to do it for themselves but they
are scared raju will do something stupid
if he doesn't pass hence they steal the
paper when raju gets a hold of it he
refuses to use it virus gets a hint of
this and barges into their room to find
the question paper on the floor he
immediately expels them all the guys
have no choice but to pack their luggage
and leave when virus returns home pia
reveals that his eldest son who had died
in an accident had actually inflicted
his own demise he did so because virus
pressured him into becoming an engineer
after relaying the news pia storms away
a while later maya goes into labor but
the city is flooded so virus cannot take
her to the hospital rancho sees this on
his way out and gets ready to help her
pia instructs him through the phone to
lay maya down on the table tennis board
they urge maya to push harder but she is
weak and can hardly breathe now the only
way to bring the baby out is by using a
device called the vacuum cup pia shows
them a demonstration of the device
through the computer which gives rancho
an idea he thinks that he can make the
device with the things that are
available around the college after a lot
of work he finally creates a makeshift
vacuum cup and uses it on her mona
finally gives birth to a beautiful baby
boy who cries after a minute of his
birth rancho is about to leave but virus
stops him and gives him the astronauts
pen that he was supposed to give to an
extraordinary student he also answers
the first question that rancho had asked
him claiming that a pencil won't be
useful in space because its nip could be
dangerous if it floats around what a
cop-out of an answer by the end of the
night he forgives the students and lets
them take the final exams in the
following scene we see the guys
graduating rancho is yet again the first
in the class as the ceremony continues
he drives away in a taxi that was the
last time farhan and raju ever saw him
they tried to contact him several times
over the years but could not find him
until now when they have his exact
address when they arrive at the place
they find out it is a school that rancho
teaches at while looking for him they
run into the janitor millimeter who has
now grown up they are told that rancho
brought him to his school so he could
get the proper education in the
following scene pia drives tarancho who
is teaching some students by a lake she
walks up to him and slaps him in the
face before kissing him soon farhan and
raju join and beat him up for abandoning
them but they understand that he had to
keep his promise to the real rancho as
the group reunites shatur also joins
them and makes fun of rancho for being a
schoolteacher he compares his million
dollar salary to rancho's 5 000 rupees
on seeing that rancho has virus's pen he
takes that away as well the rest of the
group asks rancho for his real name to
everyone's surprise he turns out to be
the great inventor mr wang doo who
shatur is hoping to sign a deal with
wangdu calls him from his number and
relays the message to him in the last
scene shatur apologizes to him and opens
his pants to show respect as per the
college's tradition
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching